is israel a rogue state its army has
killed al jazeera's journalist shirina
bakler in cold blood and this is not the
first time will israel get away with its
crimes and who can hold it to account
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
hashem
shireen abbakla was a household name
across the middle east the veteran al
jazeera journalist earned widespread
praise for more than two decades of
reporting on israel's occupation of
palestinian territory telling stories of
war atrocities and palestinian
resistance
she was shot in the head as she covered
israel's latest raid on the jinin
refugee camp in the occupied west bank
al-jazeera condemned the killing as a
blatant murder
intended to prevent journalists from
conducting their duty qatar's
called on those who assassinated shireen
to be brought to justice jamal shayal
takes a look at what we know about the
killing of shireen
[Music]
don't shoot the messenger
unless you're an israeli soldier in that
case you're seemingly okay with shooting
a reporter who's clearly identifiable as
a journalist and poses no threat
sharing
is the latest reporter to be killed by
the israeli military which has a long
history of targeting journalists and
news outlets
particularly al jazeera
chirin a veteran reporter who spent her
life covering events in occupied
palestine was among a group of
journalists documenting what was
happening in janine early on wednesday
according to eyewitnesses and video
footage she was wearing a safety vest
and helmet both of which clearly
identified her as a member of the press
despite this or maybe because of it
shireen was shot and killed
we were going to film the israeli army
operation and suddenly they shot us
without asking us to leave or stop
filming the first bullet hit me and the
second bullet hit shireen they killed
her in cold blood because they are
killers and specialize in killing only
palestinian people we had no resistance
and there was no palestinian resistance
at all at the scene
journalist ali samudi was also shot and
injured in the attack
there was no exchange of fire so there
is no possibility whatsoever that a
palestinian have shot sharing
the israeli army always uses these
excuses to cover up the crimes they are
committing against palestinians
including palestinian journalists
[Music]
according to rights groups israel has
killed 50 journalists since 2000 and
injured more than
144 in the past four years alone
this is also not the first time israel
has intentionally targeted al jazeera
last year the network's office in gaza
was bombed to rubble
while journalist gevar al-bideri was
assaulted by israeli forces whilst
reporting on israel's ethnic cleansing
of arab residents in occupied east
jerusalem's sheikh darach neighborhood
israeli authorities say they've launched
an investigation but human rights groups
say they have little faith in israeli
justice particularly with renowned
organizations like human rights watch
and amnesty international accusing
israel of implementing a system of
apartheid
[Music]
there are
human rights organizations for example
like bet salem and israeli human rights
organization
that decided a long time ago that they
are no longer going to
even interact with the complaint system
within the israeli army because it is
not serious
it doesn't find israeli soldiers guilty
qatar's foreign ministry whose country
hosts the al jazeera network issued a
statement the israeli occupation killed
al jazeera journalist shireen abu akla
by shooting her in the face while
wearing the press vest and a helmet she
was covering their attack in jeanine
refugee camp this state-sponsored
israeli terrorism must stop and
unconditional support to israel must end
the european union and other members of
the international community have also
condemned the killing
but all these condemnations have fallen
short of including any sanctioning or
punishment for a crime that threatens
the essence of any free society a free
press
sharing was killed trying to inform the
world of what was happening in her
country
the world now knows that in occupied
palestine no one is safe from israel's
bullets not even journalists
triggered international condemnation
the un's special envoy for the middle
east peace process demanded an immediate
and thorough investigation the u.s
ambassador to israel also tweeted a call
for a thorough probe into the
circumstances of her death israel has
proposed a joint inquiry but the
palestinian foreign minister said it
does not trust investigations by an
occupying state adding
they do not lead to a place other than
acquitting criminals and murderers
last month international and palestinian
media groups submitted a formal
complaint to the international criminal
court accusing israel of war crimes
against journalists the committee to
protect journalists says 24 journalists
have been killed since 2002.
that figure does not include shirina
barclay other press freedom advocates
have reported higher numbers
israel systematically targets
journalists from media outlets including
al jazeera several on board a
humanitarian flotilla heading to gaza
were detained in 2010.
a year ago this week an israeli
airstrike destroyed the officers of
al-jazeera and the associated press in
gaza
and a month later israeli soldiers
arrested al-jazeera journalist guivara
budiri as she covered protests in the
occupied east jerusalem
let's bring in our guests in west
jerusalem hagai led is executive
director
of the israeli information center for
human rights in the occupied territories
in doha
aisha al-basri researcher at the arab
center for research and policy studies
in cambridge ramihori professor of
journalism at american university of
beirut and senior fellow at the harvard
kennedy school welcome to the program
haggai
how would you characterize the position
of the israeli government
so far because when you listen to ben
against the defense minister he seems to
be implying that this could have the
fire that targeted uh shirin abu aqua
could have come from the israeli side
you have the prime minister naftali
bennett saying at the same time no we
should blame the palestinian fighters
for this
i think they've pivoted very quickly
from their initial efforts to deflect by
suggesting
uh in numerous ways from the prime
minister down uh the idf spokesperson
other government ministers the foreign
minister who is also the alternative
prime minister all very quickly
suggesting uh based on a short video
clip
that it was palestinian gunfire
that killed shirin about an injured her
colleague
and then once that was thoroughly
debunked within a few hours uh also
thanks to the work of betsalam itself
they've shifted to what is typical
their routine which is offering an
investigation
but experience very clearly demonstrates
that in the cases of such killings of
palestinians the announcement of
israel's desire or intention to
investigate does not lead to
accountability it's just the beginnings
of the beginning of the state's
organized whitewash
aisha the the the israeli government is
calling for a joint investigation the
palestinian authority says it does not
trust
a joint investigation where does this
leave the case of sherina barclay
well
let us start with this question
do we really need an investigation an
investigation it called for when there
is doubt
and from what we saw from what we heard
uh the the media professionals the
palestinians who were there just next to
sherina barclay and who were also
victims of the same attack they saw the
perpetrators their eyewitnesses and i
think they're uh they're
witnessing this this uh targeting of uh
sharing and her colleagues is quite
enough to establish this crime i i agree
with the what just has been said
uh the the investigation is an old trick
it's a strategy to
uh model waters to uh obfuscate uh by
time until the the uh the outrage and
and the tension is is diffused and that
is going to be another case or story
killed so i i i think that uh there's
enough evidence the eyewitnesses uh are
very credible unless one thinks that our
palestinians are not trustworthy to be
witnesses of of an attack that they saw
the the purpose rages and that would be
another discrimination
rami the the the the palestinian
president mahmoud abbas
said that the uh authority is going to
take the case to the icc international
criminal court do you see
the case taking that path any
any in any time soon oh it's likely that
the icc will be asked to open an
investigation a preliminary
investigation
reporters without borders and amnesty
international have already
tried to use the international criminal
court to investigate the israeli
destruction of an entire apartment block
of offices last year in gaza that had
the associated press and jazeera and
other journalists so
the likelihood of any serious action by
the icc is slim but the palestinians are
now using every opportunity available to
them
non-violently and legally
to mobilize public opinion to
lean on the rule of law to hold
zionism and israel accountable
for their actions
and i think we will see more calls of
this kind
but probably
very little independent investigation is
likely to happen but i don't think much
investigation is needed if you looked at
the washington post story this morning
by three terrific reporters on the
ground who went there and spent hours
investigating every angle every israeli
claim every palestinian claim and they
they said the evidence is pretty clear
ha guy you spoke of what happened when
the israeli government posted the video
showing uh palestinian fighters trying
to create its own narrative by
suggesting that these could be the
people who have killed shirin al-hari
except that when you stepped in as
beitel and you said this is absolutely
no way that this could have come from
those areas now when you look at that
position by the israeli government right
after the beginning of the international
outcry against the assassination of
shirin bakla do you see the potential
for an independent impartial
investigation by the israeli government
that would provide the crucial elements
of exactly what happened and the
circumstances of the killing of sharina
i mean we have an experience of
unfortunately of many years
of work of
the ability to analyze and really
understand what the israeli
investigation system is really about
it's not meant to establish
accountability it is meant to protect
the perpetrators while pushing against
the jurisdiction of international
justice
while suggesting that there is domestic
recourse well in fact there isn't so
there's a reason why israel invests all
these efforts in the public relations of
what looks like an investigation
so that there won't be international
jurisdiction while at the same time
succeeding in providing itself with
blanket impunity and i think from
israel's perspective looking back at the
record from numerous cases of killings
of palestinians in the west bank in east
jerusalem
in major military operations against
gaza the uses of snipers against
palestinian demonstrators during the
great march of return and so many other
examples
eventually israel managed to get away
with it both to maintain this reality of
committing war crimes uh and enjoying
impunity and at the same time somehow
preserving its standing
in the world
as you know a democratic nation member
of the western club of countries uh and
so on with no consequences and that's
really what is essential what must
change if we are to
eventually
get closer to some sort of justice here
aisha when you see the string of
international condemnation and
statements coming out right after the
assassination of syrian habakkuk
the eu urging an independent
investigation the united nations human
rights
chief michel bashley saying that is
about time for
uh an and to impunity in israel but do
you see
realistically a chance for a change of
behavior in israel as far as the
atrocities committed against journalists
all these statements we've been hearing
since yesterday
uh they've been actually playing at the
hands of israel because they've been
also playing the same game of casting
doubt about the testimony of the media
professional palestinians who were there
and also the perpetrators um i think
what uh what should be uh looked at
right now is the uh the big picture uh
why shane was killed i was targeted
well first of all because she was
journalists and she was chasing
the stories about the crime and exposing
them but also because she was an arab
palestinian
uh who was uh like most of the
palestinians targeted the existing
existence the rise to exist is denied by
israel and she was uh chasing the story
of upper-tide israel i think the big
picture right now
is what happened uh in in that camp
while she was there she was there
because palestinians energeting camp
they're living unto under the upper tide
israel and that is the story unless the
uh international so-called international
community deals with this issue i don't
think there will be change plus the uh
the the big uh i would say step that has
been taken by the un was actually the
report by the reporter special
approacher michael link on on 22nd march
2022
who exposed for the first time
facts that have been documented by
palestinians by bethlehem uh
organization by human rights uh watching
an amnesty international so he confirmed
that there is an apartheid in a system
in israel
and that has to be dismantled unless the
international community deals with this
issue i don't think there will be any
change rami there have been many many
reports over the last few years by
independent
media organizations in in the occupied
territories talking and documenting the
cases of abuse
killing of journalists for many years
in those areas we haven't seen an
international outcry could the case of
shireen abroakly be the moment that
would
bring together
a new awareness about the need to put an
end to targeting of journalists i doubt
it'll go that far but what it will do is
add one more
element in a
growing crescendo of international
concern
mobilization
action
uh political pressure public statements
media coverage
organizing and labor groups and and
universities all over the world that
very very slow trend in the last uh
10 15 years and especially in the last
year since last may june
and and jerusalem and other places
around palestine we've seen a
significant but slow trend uh in which
governments issue statements
but
they don't take action and now we're
seeing more and more action bds is the
main way that this is happening but
there's also law cases in the united
states parliamentary decisions in europe
labor union banks supermarkets in europe
places all saying we will not be
complicit in israel's apartheid colonial
system in the occupied palestinian
territory and treatment of palestinians
shireen's assassination will add one
more
uh push to this
and it will bring journalists more
actively into this especially since she
was a dual citizen american
and palestinian but the most critical
point i think to grasp is how this is
being framed by palestinians as part of
a 100-year struggle that this has been
going on uh since the 1920s and janine
was a center of palestinian resistance
to early zionism in the 1930s
and has been ever since as has gaza and
the israelis were sending their army one
of the strongest armies in the world
into this warren of
the little streets in the refugee camp
with massive firepower intelligence
satellite everything you can think of
and they still can't uh quell it they
cannot stop the resistance in janine and
that's why they were there and that's
why shireen was there and that's why she
was shot
so this is a bigger story and the
context
has to be appreciated as an ongoing
resistance war by palestinians mostly
peaceful against a colonial zionist
israeli
move since the
19th 1915 1917
the balance is still in israel's favor
politically globally but it is slowly
slowly moving towards more even-handed
positions this is important
i would like your view about about i
guess the backdrop of what we've been
talking about
now bet salem the organization that you
work for has been doing an extraordinary
work over the last few years in
documenting human rights violations in
the israeli occupied territories now
the israeli government has been really
angered by some of your reports to the
point where it has been trying to
produce new reports parallel reports to
discredit your narrative at the same
time to give you an uh an example 2019
the united nations human rights council
commissioners report about
it found that there are indications on
the ground that israeli snipers have
been targeting
palestinian journalists who are trying
to cover what was happening on the
ground the israeli government rejected
the findings saying that these are
kangaroo court reports the the way the
israeli government has been dealing with
your report or with the reports from the
international community
what kind of message that is sent
to the people yes maybe if you allow me
just before i address that i want to add
one more thing about the how critical
the impunity is for israel's oppression
of palestinians
and what i want to spell out is is the
following it's impossible to conduct
such an oppressive apartheid regime
against an entire people over decades
without the usage of organized state
violence all the time to take their land
uh to control them to oppress them um so
their violence is an essential aspect of
israel's ability to do this to the
palestinian people but it has to come
hand in hand with the impunity because
if israel doesn't grant itself to
impunity then it doesn't have the
ability to apply this kind of violence
and successfully control the
palestinians
so this is strategic it's a cornerstone
of israel's regime it has to be
understood as a feature of this of this
system now with regard to the way the
government addresses our reports and the
reports of you know other human rights
organizations of palestinian colleagues
international organizations and so on
it's very typical a response that
doesn't address the substance because
they really can't argue with the facts
and with the analysis instead of that
they have to try and shoot the messenger
uh try and uh you know present us as
traitors or in the case of palestine
colleagues typically the government
would try to present them as terrorists
and with regard to international
entities uh usually the government will
use accusations of anti-semitism okay uh
the icc
in itself was played by the former prime
minister as both supportive of terrorism
and anti-semitism aisha briefly if you
don't mind could it be this prevailing
sentiment in particular in the west that
you know
you know what because these this is a
part of the world where you have
dictators where you have instability and
so on and so forth and violence and
radical groups you know what who cares
about the fate of the journalists when
they die because you don't get the same
response
when it comes to a similar case where a
western journalist is targeted is
targeted or is killed
well i think the the main reason is is
because israel israel is actually the
the product the byproducts of
western colonial uh settlers and uh
this is their baby basically so this is
whatever israel is doing is the result
of the uh their creation uh which juana
unfortunately uh contributed to uh
through the the partition uh resolution
and uh
all over the the the the action and lack
of action it another took so that's uh
that's basically the the uh the reason
why they
they are they don't want to what to hold
israel to account but the u.n has a
major role to play uh i would say first
that uh it has to follow up on the a
micro length report on the uh upper tide
israel and the need for dismantling it
second there is a u.n security security
council resolution two three three four
that was adopted in 2016 which calls on
ending the occupation and also and in
the illegal settlements that also has to
to to uh needs a follow-up by the the
palestine the state of palestine there
is also
the icc the icc we haven't heard karim
khanna he was very quick uh to uh to to
take the first uh
uh plane to uh to ukraine and and start
the investigation and we haven't heard
from him on when it comes to palestine
it's been one year since
so uh these are the three uh major uh
uh decision makers that need to do uh
the right thing in order to dismantle
the opportunity thank you very much
indeed this is exactly what sharing
about said
when she was last interviewed i first
went into jeanine refugee camp
20 years ago before that i had to
overcome my fear i chose to become a
journalist because i wanted to be close
to people
really appreciate your insight thank you
and thank you for watching you can see
the program again anytime by visiting
our website al jazeera.com for further
discussion go to our facebook page
that's facebook.com forward slash aj
inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj insidestory from me hashem
and the entire team here in doha bye for
now
[Music]
you